Here's a tip for you.
Don't use white backgrounds.
If you've ever taken a walk through a park and seen a glint of a gum wrapper off in the distance,...
...or more likely today a beer can, and been completely distracted, you're gonna understand this.
We see it light, not dark.
In fact, we have 128 million rods and cones in each eye...
...and that's what they do, they look for light.
When light hits them, they send electric currents to the brain.
More light produces more electric current.
So think about the last time you tried to stare at a bright, glaring light.
After a short time, it's really tiring.
Too much electric current to the brain.
Now think about the presentation situation:...
...a semidark room with a projector shooting bright light...
...onto a reflective screen and back into the eyes of the audience.
Electric current to the brain like crazy.
After a half hour of looking into white light, your audience is gonna look like this.
Do this experiment: create a slide with black text on a white background...
...then have your audience look at it, then reverse it and listen to the sigh of relief.
Bright white reflected light is distracting, there's no two ways about it.
In fact, it's electrifying.
I call white backgrounds, "white death."
Don't go there.